[Musica]
oggi è il compleanno della nostra
repubblica
sono 75 anni 75 anni fa
i nostri nonni e le nostre nonne rossi
papà e le nostre mamme andavano per la
prima volta de urne per votare in un
referendum
dovevano scegliere tra repubblica e
monarchia
spesso mi figuro quel giorno mi chiedo
se nell'aria si percepisse il
cambiamento se le persone sentissero il
peso della responsabilità sulla loro
spagna se sognassero un futuro come
quello che stiamo vivendo oggi
beh magari proprio in questo però credo
fermamente che con quel piccolo gesto
però volessero allontanarsi il più
possibile da quello che era stato e
costruire qualcosa di nuovo è qualcosa
di nuovo è stato costruito migliore di
ciò che l'ha preceduto
come disse churchill la democrazia è la
peggiore forma di governo ma ad eccezion
fatta per tutte le altre che abbiamo
sperimentato fino ad oggi
oggi infatti ci troviamo di fronte a
qualcosa di completamente diverso che
può essere migliore o peggiore e questo
dipende solo da ognuno di noi ormai
molte delle nostre attività si svolgono
su internet e la politica
l'opinione pubblica è stata
completamente sconvolta è cambiata da
questo la capacità di interazione
diretta di risposte di ricerca delle
informazioni che ci permette internet
2.0
l'internet dei social per capirci ha
stravolto completamente la comunicazione
pubblica quella che prima avveniva
attraverso dei mediatori che erano i
partiti che erano le associazioni adesso
può venire direttamente ognuno di noi
può parlare direttamente con un politico
un politico può rivolgersi direttamente
con noi a noi i social ci aprono al
mondo a button e confini statali
ognuno di noi può potenzialmente
arrivare a quasi ovunque ormai
l'informazione è ormai liberata quelle
mediazioni di cui vi ho parlato prima
e con questa liberazione ognuno di noi
diventa creatore delle proprie categorie
di importanza non è più lo stato a dirci
cosa dovrebbe essere fatto prima cosa
dopo ciò che è importante
al contrario i partiti che sono rimaste
lì ad ascoltare le nostre conversazioni
che avvengono sui social raccolgono idee
e informazioni e cercano di capire cosa
mettere in cima alla loro lista per
vincere le prossime elezioni
quindi da una parte questa nostra
libertà di discernimento ci rende
liberi e sta modificando completamente
il sistema politico
dall'altra ci mette di fronte
all'importanza che ognuno di noi ha
rispetto alle decisioni che verranno
prese in futuro perché quello che noi
scriviamo quello di cui noi parliamo
quotidianamente viene la presa sul serio
da qualcuno quindi quando pensiamo di
non fare la differenza
dovremmo riflettere su questo sul fatto
che ognuno di noi ha una responsabilità
su quello che potrebbe accadere domani
si tratta di una sfida sicuramente
perché parliamo alla responsabilità del
singolo
parliamo di ognuno di noi e il fatto di
avere a disposizione tutta la conoscenza
dell'uomo
da una parte rende possibile
allontanarsi dall ignoranza dall'altra
fa sì che molti di noi si accontentino e
ascoltino l'opinione degli altri non
vadano a ricercare la realtà e lasciano
che siano i filtri di qualcun altro a
dire ciò che è giusto e ciò che è
sbagliato ciò che è vero e ciò che è
falso
e poi c'è un grosso pericolo soprattutto
le fake news
si tratta letteralmente di menzogne
costruite ad arte per diventare virali
senza pensare alla reazione che questa
serialità a sul mondo che ci circonda
ma perché
hanno questa importanza perché riescono
a convincerci perché riescono a
distoglierci da quell enorme quantità di
verità e di conoscenza che c'è su
internet
vedete il potere delle fec news non sta
in chi le urla in chi ne racconto anche
se le inventa sta in chi l'ascolta
perché
il fatto che noi ci crediamo significa
semplicemente che abbiamo smesso di
ricercare la verità una società che
smette di cercare la verità
concentrandosi sulle proprie emozioni e
potenzialmente devastante perché la
maggior parte dei casi la maggior parte
delle volte le mozioni su cui ci si
concentra e l'odio ed è assurdo che
proprio noi nipoti figli di quei primi
che andarono a votare per regalarci un
futuro diverso
ci lasciamo trascinare e ci
accontentiamo di bugie di mezze verità
come se non pensassimo come se non
conoscessimo col passato così vicino
quello che i nostri nonni hanno visto
con le loro contro rocchi invece è una
cosa che accade troppo spesso molto più
di quanto immaginiamo
vi racconto una cosa che non è successa
mentre stavo scrivendo la mia tesi
magistrale che da qualche mese è
diventato un libro di cui sono molto
orgogliosa
mentre ricercavo le fonti per questa
tesi mi sono imbattuta in un enorme
quantità di interviste a negazionisti un
negazionista in quel contesto è una
persona che è convinta che l'olocausto
non si è mai avvenuto
è un accademico
che cerca di convincerti che quelle
persone non sono morte che quell
avvenimento non è mai avvenuto ho
ascoltato le loro interviste per ore e
dopo ore e ore di lettura e ascolto un
certo punto anche per me che stavo
scrivendo una tesi sul contrario di
quello che stava dicendo la verità non
era più così vera e l'occhio non era più
così ovvio dovuto chiudere tutto
mi sono alzata ricordo che sono andata
in cucina da mia madre l'ho guardata da
letto mamma io non so più cosa è vero e
cosa è falso è dovuto chiudere tutto per
qualche ora perché tutto si allineasse
perché la verità diventasse unica
tornarsi ad essere l'unica però la
facilità con cui la mia mente si è
piegata mi ha sconvolto e ha cambiato
completamente il mio rapporto con la
verità dobbiamo capire che la nostra
capacità di discernimento non deve
essere data per scontata
dobbiamo sempre dedicare una riflessione
a quello che ci viene detto assicurarci
che quello che ci viene detto si basino
su delle verità sono le questioni reali
dobbiamo in un mondo in cui le notizie
si moltiplicano di continuo assicurarci
di non lasciar filtrare andare a
ricercare noi la notizia e assicurarci
che la verità non sia vera
un antico metodo di tortura cinese
faceva sì che il torturato venisse
legato posizionata con la testa verso
l'alto e una doccia gelata di acqua
facesse cadere questi sulla testa di
continuo ritmicamente all'infinito
l'obiettivo dei torturatori bucare il
cane poi naturalmente questa cosa non
era possibile perché sarebbero voluti
decine centinaia di anni ma dopo qualche
ora il malcapitato impazziva e dopo
qualche giorno moriva d'ipotermia perché
vi sto raccontando questo perché se
quella goccia avesse avuto il suo tempo
il cane o lo avrebbe forato un idea
sentimento ripetuto continuamente per un
tempo se misurato finisce per piegare
anche le menti più saltano anche chi di
noi ha convinto di avere le idee piu
convinte più forti
la goccia che cade continuamente
ci ha convinti che in realtà non è colpa
nostra se come sta accadendo nel male e
dell'odio
alcuni pochi tenteranno di ribellarsi
cercheranno di spostare la testa di non
ascoltare è però non è una cosa facile
siamo legati stretti alla nostra società
siamo legati stretti alle nostre
famiglie i nostri amici
molti di loro sono convinti hanno teste
bucate da un sacco di gocce moltiplicano
le gocce che cadono sulla nostra testa
però attenzione facciamo un passo
indietro perché gli strumenti per
ribellarci le abbiamo menzionati qualche
secondo fa abbiamo detto che l'odio è il
sentimento più facile da veicolare e
purtroppo il mondo digitale il mondo di
internet non fa che confermarlo
ma adesso abbiamo la consapevolezza con
noi abbiamo detto che in un mondo che
questo mondo ci sta mettendo a
disposizione tutto lo scibile umano
tutta la conoscenza e che sta a noi è la
nostra consapevolezza nostra volontà
andare a ricercare i nostri amici hanno
lasciato un'eredità inestimabile la
democrazia la repubblica e soprattutto
la loro esperienza e il loro passato e
ancora vicino
75 anni guardare indietro e guardare con
la loro prospettiva significa poter
guardare avanti cercando di costruire un
mondo che non possa e non debba basarsi
sull'odio nessuno di noi deve essere
nelle condizioni di essere convinto da
un'idea perché veicolato dall'odio
abbiamo tutti gli strumenti perché
questo mondo diventi la versione
migliore di se stessi ma tutto sta in
ognuno di noi le nostre dita sulla
tastiera sono un'arma e allora tocca a
noi decidere di riempire di fiori i
nostri cannoni